vasy fais voir fais voir mais non j'ai
pas beso que
tuesc rien à
voirourourouchetion
Gén je suis très
content trèri sur les fréquentations ah
non on va surt je m'en fous pas cool les
par
coolarrive
pasise maman je suis là maintenant je
m'en vais
plus es pas quand tu as fait de la chim
c'est que les Mousti t'emmerd plus
j'ai jamais changé un gos j'ai jamais
baby sitting pour ça tombe sur moi
d'avoir un
enfant tu comprends es en train de faire
beaucoup de mal tu pas fout prend ton
[__] de courage à demain d'aller voir
ta propre mère et d'aller lui dire maman
tu vas être grand-mère elle jamais été
mère comment tu veux qu'elle soit
grand-mère
my little baby having a
baby